on a vu nous deux brancardiers apporter
une civière en marcher en direction donc
de de ce supermarché là voilà explosion
on est en cours voilà c'est parti même
scénario jeis essayer de me placer pour
que vous puissiez voir derrière moi on a
entendu une grenade assourdissante très
probablement l'assut est en cours deuxè
explosion colonne de fumée que l'on voit
actuellement de la troème explosion
l'opération est en cours actuellement
porte de V scen à
Paris dans ce supermarché où est
retranché amedi
Coulibali cinq CQ ottages avec lui
effectivement donc pour l'instant ce que
c'est surtout des bruits que l'on entend
on entend des cris le le la procédure
est toujours la même dans ce cas-là on
s'attend donc à ce que les hommes
d'élite de du raid cette unité d'élite
de la police nationale donne l'assut
maintenant c'est toujours la même chose
on vient d'entendre donc